-Last time I saw you
was at the Golden Globes,
backstage at
the Golden Globes.
-Yes, it was at
And actually,
moments after I saw you,
I had a horrible incident
that I have not spoken about.
Even -- I think I actually
just told my wife about it.
'Cause it was -- it was --
So, I saw you at
the Golden Globes.
I was supposed to go on
and present a --
Like, a spiel about
"The Disaster Artist."
And I'd say --
Someone came up to me.
And I was backstage,
and they're like,
"So you're going to go on
in like three minutes."
And I was like, "Perfect."
And then I bent down
to pick up something,
and I blew out my pants
from like the very front
to the very back.
Like full -- Like chaps.
I chaps'd them.
And from, like, my --
Yeah, the whole thing was gone.
And I just --
I didn't know what to do.
They were just like,
"All right. 60 seconds."
And I just -- I frantically --
It would take too long
to explain it to anyone.
So I grabbed --
I just saw a stylist who was --
I think it was Felicity Jones.
-Yeah.
-Her stylist.
And I just literally grabbed
just, like,
a rack of safety pins,
went into the bathroom,
took my pants off,
turned them inside out, pinned
them with 15 safety pins all up,
making, like,
a metallic stitching thing
from the base of my butt
to the top of my crotch.
And then the second I fastened
the last one, they're like,
"We're ready for you on stage."
And I went out with essentially,
like, a diaper
made of safety pins...
holding my pants together, yeah.
-That's so fantastic.
-Yeah.
-I feel like --
-I did it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I feel like you should get
a special Golden Globe
for Technical Achievement.
-It's true.
I think they announced a new
Oscar category for it, actually.
So, yeah,
that could be one of them.
-So, your wife wrote
and directed this film.
-Yes.
-Kristen Bell plays a woman
who is left at the alter, has to
still go on her honeymoon trip.
She goes with her father,
Kelsey Grammer.
-Yes.
-You guys actually shot it
on a functional cruise ship.
-We did.
-How was that?
-I did not like that.
-Okay.
-I don't know
if you've been on a cruise.
It's like if someone took,
like, the world's biggest buffet
and set it adrift.
And that's kind of...
[ Applause ]
...what it's like.
It's just -- It's weird.
And people --
There is literally videos
that tell you
to wash your hands.
Because people
don't wash their hands...
-Yeah.
-...and just shove them
in, like, the ham spread
or whatever they have.
And then you get, like,
a cruise-ship dysentery
or something like that.
And so they make
these little jingles.
They're like...
♪♪ Wash your hands ♪♪
And you're like,
"It's a nice song,
but the root of it
is disgusting."
And, yeah, it felt like --
It was very weird.
It was a weird environment.
Ultimately, like,
from a sociological standpoint,
I guess, it was interesting.
-In the film, you play --
As we can tell from a clip,
you're a little awkward.
-I'm very awkward. Yes.
-You also are Canadian
in the film.
-I play a guy named Jeff, yes,
from Edmonton, Alberta, Canada,
as he says in the film.
And that was -- He was already
Canadian when my wife cast me,
which was harder
than you would hope,
once she agreed
to allow me to be in her film.
The guy was Canadian.
And he would just say,
"I'm from Edmonton."
And something,
as a Canadian, I know
is when you're explaining
to Americans where you're from,
you say the city, the province,
and the country.
'Cause we don't assume
any American
has heard of any one of
those things necessarily.
And I've -- I'm from Vancouver,
British Columbia, Canada.
And I've had to say that like --
Vancouver? Nothing.
British Columbia?
That's, like, confusing.
Like, "What? There's
a British Colombia now?
When did that happen?"
And then -- And by the time
you get to "Canada,"
most people have heard of that.
But even that, you -- I've had
some crossed wires in the past.
So, yeah.
So that's what Canadians do.
City, province, country.
Hopefully one of those things
is identifiable. Yes.
-There's a scene in the film
where Kelsey and Kristen are --
They play, like,
a game show on the cruise,
which I guess is a thing
that happens on cruises.
-It is, yes.
If you're not enticed enough,
yeah, there's game shows.
-But you and your sister
were actually on a game show
when you were kids.
-We were. We were on a show
called "Kidstreet,"
which is a Canadian show
that was kind of like
"The Newlywed Game"
with siblings.
Not in the gross way.
And so it was -- You and
your sibling were separated,
and you were asked questions,
and you had to match up
your answers hypothetically,
you know?
What's your favorite food?
Pizza. Pizza.
And so my dad, though --
We got on the show.
And my dad watched hundreds
of episodes of the show
and realized that you could
break down every answer
into one of like 10 categories.
Like, there was
food-related questions.
There was location-related
questions.
There was number-related
And he set answers
with me and my sister
so if it was anything
to do with food, pizza.
Anything to do with a location?
Hawaii.
-So that'd be, like,
least favorite food, pizza.
-Favorite food. Pizza.
What do you eat most for dinner?
Pizza.
Doesn't matter.
If it's food, pizza.
So we do this.
My dad sets out a series
of like 10 answers.
We memorize them.
And not only does it work,
we don't get one question wrong,
and we won the game show
through cheating.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Just through --
just sheer cheating.
Yeah.
And I think in America today,
it's the best lesson
a child can learn,
is if you cheat, you will win.
-Yeah.
-So do it.
-I would say that the lesson
that was imparted upon you
by your father
is one that Trump probably
has taught all of his children.
-Just cheat, guys.
-Just cheat.
It works out great.
-It's why I'm so Trumpian.